[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend mit mir im Studio für den
sportlichen Teil später wieder Christin
to genau in 15 Minuten guten Abend dann
blicken wir gemeinsam auf unsere
heutigen Themen regieren mit
milliardenlücke das
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil stellt
wichtige Vorhaben der Ampelkoalition in
Frage
Weltsicherheitsrat verlangt Feuerpausen
Israel fordert die Menschen im Süden des
gaserastreifens auf zu
fliehen Geduldsprobe für Bahnreisende
durch den Warnstreik der
lockführergewerkschaft GDL fällt ein
Großteil der Züge
aus die Ampel muss sich gerade die 60
Milliarden Euro Frage stellen und hat
wohl keinen Joker mehr übrig wie und
womit soll man so ein riesen Finanzloch
stopfen karlsruh hat ja gestern
entschieden ungenutzte coronakredite
dürfen nicht für den Klimaschutz
ausgegeben werden so hatte es die
Bundesregierung ja vor und verplante die
megasumme das sehen wir jetzt in der
Erklärung von Antoine kurchilgen für den
sogenannten
KTF KTF das steht für Klima und
transformationsfond und ist ein
Sondertopf außerhalb des
Bundeshaushalts ursprünglich knapp 212
Milliarden Euro groß überwiegend
finanziert durch Schulden nur ein
kleiner Teil sind eigene Einnahmen aus
Emissionshandel und CO2 Bepreisung rund
19 Milliarden Euro gefördert werden soll
die klimafreundliche Sanierung von
Wohnhäusern und der Austausch alter Öl
und Gasheizungen bis
2027 60 Milliarden Euro weitere Mittel
rund 18,6 Milliarden Euro für die
wasserstoffindustrie rund 13,8
Milliarden für die Elektromobilität und
12,5 Milliarden für die
Eisenbahninfrastruktur auch staatliche
Fördergelder für halbleiterfabriken wie
die des US Chipherstellers Intel in
Magdeburg kommen aus dem KTF und Bürger
sowie Unternehmen sollen bei den
Strompreisen entlastet werden durch den
Wegfall der
ökostromumlage FDP Finanzminister
Lindner schließt Steuererhöhungen heute
aus und setzt eher aufs Sparen kein
Geheimnis das SPD und Grüne sich da was
anderes vorstellen es dürfte also wieder
rappeln im regierungskarton bei den
Berliner Haushaltsberatungen wurde eines
heute auch deutlich für die Opposition
sind die ursprünglichen etaplanungen
nach dem Karlsruher Urteil nicht mehr
viel wert Patrizia
Wiedemeier es sind tausende Seiten die
der haushaltspolitische Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion für die Sitzung des
Haushaltsausschusses gestapelt hat dass
diese überhaupt noch Sinn macht daran
zweifelt er dem
Haushalt ist im Grunde die Grundlage
entzogen 60 Milliarden müssen jetzt
zusätzlich beschafft werden das ist
vollkommen offen wo und wie das geht
nach dem Urteil von gestern ist klar der
et für das Jahr 24 kann nicht wie
geplant diese Woche abschließend beraten
werden zeitgleich heute Nachmittag
aktuelle Stunde im Bundestag
Finanzminister Lindner verteidigt die
Schuldenbremse lehnt Steuererhöhungen
weiter ab wie alle geplanten Projekte
der Ampel finanziert werden sollen von
ihm so viel wir werden mit weniger Geld
wirksamere Politik machen müssen als im
vergangenen Jahrzehnt wir haben kein
Einnahmeproblem sondern wir haben ein
Problem damit schon seit vielen Jahren
Prioritäten zu setzen welche Prioritäten
das lässt er offen heftige Kritik von
der Opposition Herr
Bundesfinanzminister sie haben keinen
Plan und die Menschen fragen sich
zurecht ist es denn ihre Arroganz oder
ist es ihre Verzweiflung wie es nun
weitergeht bleibt offen der
Wirtschaftsminister hält an der
Transformation der wirtschaftfest der
Kanzler verspricht für das nächste Jahr
rekordinvestitionen in die Infrastruktur
es muss dann eben anders gehen es kann
nicht so sein dass wir sagen dann machen
wir es eben nicht jedenfalls ich bin
nicht bereit das zu akzeptieren und das
einfach so hinzunehmen dass dann diese
Arbeitsplätze jetzt unter Druck geraten
oder aus Deutschland verschwinden dass
wir eine rekordquote bei Investitionen
erreichen das wird in jedem Fall
gewährleistet sein und wir werden das
auch sicherstellen es ist für die
Funktionsfähigkeit unserer
Volkswirtschaft von größter Bedeutung
doch wie das alles finanziert werden
soll das bleibt auch heute die große
Frage wir gehen nach Berlin zu Diana
Zimmermann Diana einen Tag nach der
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes welchen
Eindruck macht die Ampel auf dich ja die
Mitglieder der Ampel wirkten heute immer
noch wie erstarrt allerdings konnte man
ihre Grundmuster ganz gut erkennen der
Kanzler betonte es werde alles gut der
Wirtschaftsminister dass man nicht am
Klimaschutz sparen dürfe und der
Finanzminister machte klar dass es mit
ihm weder Steuererhöhung noch ein
Aufweichen der Schuldenbremse geben
würde nichts konkretes dazu aber wie das
verhindert werden kann was der Klima und
transformationsfond verhindern sollte
das nämlich die Industrie aus
Deutschland abwandert weil ihr hier die
Energiepreise zu hoch sind und dass die
Bürger von den Maßnahmen zum Klimaschutz
finanziell überfordert werden nichts
Konkretes also dazu wie gespart werden
kann auch nicht ob und welche
Subventionen jetzt wegfallen sollen dazu
tagt seit heute Mittag der Haushalt dort
geht es traditionell hoch her und das
oft bis in die frühen Morgenstunden und
das wird sicher sicherlich auch für
heute der Fall sein denn dort muss man
sehr konkret werden und das nun unter
extrem großen Schmerzen danke für die
Einschätzung nach Berlin Diana
Zimmermann der Bundestag hat mit mit
großer Mehrheit die Länder Georgien und
Moldau als sichere Herkunftsstaaten für
geflüchtete eingestuft in beiden Staaten
drohe den Menschen keine politische
Verfolgung so Innenministerin fäer durch
die Bestimmung könnten Asylverfahren
stark beschleunigt werden mehr als jeder
zehnte abgelehnte Asylantrag komme aus
Georgien und
Moldau nach einigen Anläufen hat sich
der Weltsicherheitsrat erstmals auf eine
Resolution zum Gazakrieg geeinigt darin
werden sofort Feuerpausen für humanitäre
Hilfe und die bedingungslose Freilassung
aller Geiseln gefordert der Entwurf
wurde ohne Gegenstimme angenommen die
USA haben überraschend auf einen Veto
verzichtet und enthielten sich eben so
wie Russland und Großbritannien obwohl
die Resolution völkerrechtlich bindend
ist erteilte Israel der Forderung nach
längeren Feuerpausen umgehend eine
Absage und das wollen wir noch mal
einordnen Alisa jung ist für uns vor den
Vereinten Nationen in New York Alisa
welche Durchschlagskraft kann diese
Resolution
haben es stimmt eigentlich sind die
Resolutionen des un Sicherheitsrats
völkerrechtlich bindend aber was hat die
UN für Möglichkeiten wenn sich Israel
daran nicht hält sie könnte Sanktionen
verhängen sie könnte theoretisch
militärisch militärisch eingreifen sie
könnte denn dafür bräucht es eine neue
Resolution das ist mehr als
unwahrscheinlich dass die USA als
Schutzmacht Isra
sich da nicht entgegenstellen würden sie
würden da ihr Veto einlegen
höchstwahrscheinlich und sie haben jetzt
der Resolution für die humanitären
Pausen nur deshalb sich nicht
entgegenentstellt sondern
entgegengestellt sondern nur enthalten
weil sie eben diese formale Forderung
nach einem Waffenstillstand vermieden
hat und trotzdem nicht nur der
internationale Druck sondern auch der
Druck im eigenen Land hier in den USA
bezüglich der israelpitik der beiden
Regierung der steigt mehr als 400
Mitarbeiter in den Regierungsbehörden
fordern genau das einen sofortigen
Waffenstillstand aber diese Wirkung der
Resolution die ist begrenzt wenn sich
nicht Israel selbst dafür entscheidet
den Krieg zu beenden und das ist
natürlich mehr als unwahrscheinlich so
lange Hamers existiert und mehr als 200
Menschen mehr als 200 Geiseln in der
Gewalt hat vielen Dank nach New York
Alisa jung war das für uns also der
internationale Druck auf Israel steigt
aber auch innenpolitisch steht
Regierungschef netanahu weiter massiv in
der Kritik Ex-Ministerpräsident und
Oppositionsführer Lapid forderte heute
den Rück tritt von Netanyahu im
Gazastreifen setzt die israelische Armee
ihren Einsatz weiter fort und gut
möglich dass dieser auch auf den Süden
ausgeweitet wird mehr von Stefan
Schlösser keine Feuerpause Israel greift
weiter Ziele an vergangene Nacht
brachten Soldaten auch den Hafen von
gazaastadt unter ihre Kontrolle der
Sprecher des Außenministeriums erwidert
auf die unresolution der Sicherheitsrat
solle weiter auf die Freilassung aller
Geiseln bestehen und die Hamas eindeutig
verurteilen weitere äuerungen hält die
Regierung offenbar nicht für nötig im
vermeintlich sicheren Süden von Gaza
fielen heute Flugblätter vom Himmel
abgeworfen von der israelischen Armee
die die Menschen auffordert ihre
Unterkünfte zu verlassen möglicherweise
will sie auch hier gegen
hamasterroristen
Vorgehen israel hat die Menschen
aufgefordert nach Süden zu gehen das
haben wir gemacht jetzt sagen Sie wir
sollen wieder gehen aber wohin wir
möchten verstehen wo genau wir hin
sollen re Lage verschlechtert sich
zusehens Versorgung Unterkünfte und
Krankenhäuser alles schon jetzt längst
am
Limit das gesamte medizinische Personal
arbeitet unter sehr großem Druck wir
müssen uns um die Verletzten kümmern und
jetzt auch noch um die Menschen die aus
dem Norden vertrieben
worden der kibut Beeri wo die Hamas
Terroristen am schlimmsten wüteten heute
führte der israelische Außenminister
EU-Vertreter durch die zerstörte
Siedlung darunter auch der
Außenbeauftragte er warnt Israel dürfe
sich verteidigen die palästinensische
Zivilbevölkerung aber nicht
vergessen ich verstehe eure Wut aber
lasst mich euch bitten euch nicht von
der Wut aufzehren zu
lassen bisher keine Signale dass Israel
von seinem harten Kurs abweichen
könnte nach Deutschland die
Ermittlungsbehörden sind mit einer
großratiia in sieben Bundesländern gegen
mutmaßlich islamistische Organisation
vorgegangen im Mittelpunkt steht der
Verein islamisches Zentrum Hamburg die
Polizei stellte im Hauptsitz der Blauen
Moschee Handys Computer und
Schriftstücke sicher der Verein steht im
Verdacht die proiranische
Terrororganisation Hisbollah zu
unterstützen ich hoffe Sie haben es gut
überstanden der Streik der Lockführer
ist offiziell seit einer Stunde beendet
und dennoch rollt jetzt nicht alles
planmäßig und auch morgen werden die
Folgen des Streiks wohl noch zu spüren
sein tausende Verbindungen wur heute
gestrichen und gut möglich dass schon
bald der nächste Hammer droht und kommt
Gewerkschaftschef weselski der Schloss
jedenfalls weitere Streiks nicht aus
Scarlet Sternberg
berichtet in Hannover fährt
hauptsächlich die Konkurrenz der Bahn
heute am Streiktag der Gewerkschaft
deutscher Lokomotivführer viele
Kundinnen und Kunden haben sich damit
arrangiert ich fahre morgen nach Hause
ich habe jetzt eine Nacht noch dazu und
geh jetzt gerade ins DB Reisezentrum um
das zu klären so viel fährt ja heute
nicht also soweit erst einmal die
Herausforderung die Züge zu finden die
in meine Richtung überhaupt gerade
fahren alle davor und dre Stunden danach
fallen aus meiner ist der einzige der
fährt also ich habe richtig Glück nur
20% der Züge fahren im Fernverkehr der
Deutschen Bahn in einer Stunde endet der
Streik doch auch danach gilt noch ein
Notfahrplan wir bitten um Verständnis
dass danach nicht gleich wieder alles
perfekt laufen kann die Züge werden erst
nach und nach wieder in den Fahrplan
eingereiht wir müssen die Verkehre die
Züge über Nacht so ordnen dass wir
morgen wieder überall planmäßig auf die
Schiene gehen können für heute dauert es
also noch bis die regulären Fahrpläne
wieder gelten die gdlspitze ist
weiterhin entschlossen wir bewegen uns
beim Warnstreik immer in der Frage der
Verhältnismäßigkeit wir haben deshalb
nur die 20 Stunden angesetzt die
Ergebnisse sind 1A ich habe eine volle
Beteiligung aller unsere Mitglieder und
so demonstrierten sie heute in Schwerin
weitere Warnstreiks sind auch in der
Vorweihnachtszeit im Streit mit der Bahn
nicht ausgeschlossen
zwischen den USA und China gibt's ja
zahlreiche Konfliktpunkte nach langer
Funkstille trafen sich die Präsidenten
beiden und she jetzt bei San Francisco
zu einem Gespräch sie vereinbarten dass
die Militärs beider Seiten die
Kommunikation wieder aufnehmen und
wollen auch persönlich im Krisenfall
miteinander telefonieren auch wenn
keines der großen Streitthemen
ausgeräumt wurde zeigten sich beiden
undi nach dem Treffen
versönnlich Spanien ist der Sozialist
Pedro Sanchez vom Parlament wieder zum
Ministerpräsidenten gewählt worden
allerdings nur dank umstrittener
Zugeständnisse für Regionalparteien
Sanchez Sozialisten hatten bei der
Parlamentswahl im Juli keine eigene
Mehrheit erreicht um sich trotzdem die
nötigen Stimmen zu sichern sagte er
katalanischen Separatisten eine Amnestie
zu was zu Protesten
führte in der Drogerie da fehlt das
Lieblingsshampoo dann das
supermarktmüsli aktuell gibt es
jedenfalls viele leere Regale und grund
dafür sind mehrere tarifkonflikte im
Großhandel und im Einzelhandel seit
Monaten laufen die ungewöhnlich harten
Verhandlungen für den Einzelhandel
fordert die Gewerkschaft unter anderem
2,50 € mehr pro Stunde mindestens aber
13,50 € die Arbeitgeber sind davon weit
entfernt katr
Lindner marktchef Grube sagt es sei wie
ein Lotteriespiel diesmal fehlt die
Butter mal ist es die Milch oder das
Gemüse es kommt immer darauf an welches
Lager streigt und das geht seit einem
halben Jahr so dieser kleine Karton ist
eine Menge für etwa eine Stunde und wir
haben eine Öffnung von 15 Stunden am Tag
das heißt der nächst die nächsten kund
die in einer Stunde kommt finden keine
Butter mehr vor seit einem halben Jahr
laufen Warnstreiks 66% der Beschäftigten
sind Frauen im Handel viele von ihnen
prekär beschäftigt auch weil sie wenige
Stunden bekommen als sie gern arbeiten
würden so die Gewerkschaft wir die
wirklich immer da sind gerade
Weihnachten Ostern kämpfen für unsere
Kunden und Kriegen arschritt ich muss
halt gucken ich muss sparen also ich
kann mir nicht das leisten was ich an
der Theke verkaufe und wir haben riesige
Flucht an Personal was in andere Berufe
den wechselt weil sie einfach kein Bock
mehr haben für den geringen Lohn
irgendwie die harte Arbeit zu machen die
Gewerkschaft will bei den Verhandlungen
die Inflationsrate herausholen und eine
Tarifsteigerung erzielen das bisherige
Angebot der Arbeitgeber liegt darunter
die Fronten sind
verhärtet und ich weiß jetzt schon bei
diesem Angebot wäre schwierig das in der
gesamten Breite des Einzelhandels zu
vermitteln weil viele Unternehmen
kämpfen momentan um das Überleben und
werden sich auch einen höheren Abschluss
gar nicht leisten können Jacqueline
schunemann ist gelernte Verkäuferin und
verdient rund 18 € brutto pro Stunde
viele ihrer Kollegen wie Packer und
auffüller weit
weniger der umstrittene
Unkrautvernichter Glyphosat darf weitere
10 Jahre in der EU verwendet werden das
hat die EU-Kommission entschieden zuvor
gab es unter den EU-Staaten weder eine
Mehrheit für ein Verbot noch für die
weitere Zulassung für den
glyphosateinsatz soll es allerdings
Bedingungen geben Pufferstreifen etwa
die andere Pflanzen schützen außerdem
darf jedes EU-Land die Verwendung auf
nationaler und regionaler Ebene
einschränken es ist eine der
renommiertesten Auszeichnungen für
Fernsehschaffende der Hans Joachim
friedrichspreis in diesem Jahr geht er
an den Leiter des ZDF Studios Washington
Elmar twesen die Jury würdigte ihn für
seine souveräne Sachkenntnis und den
scharfen Blick für die großen
Zusammenhänge außerdem ausgezeichnet die
Leiterin des ARD Studios Moskau Ina
Rock jetzt mal wir sportlich weiter
Christin das letzte Fußball Länderspiel
steht an noch ach so das vorletzte okay
aber es läuft geräuschlos allerdings
harmonisch und fokussiert 7 Monate vor
beginnen der heimem gibt Samstagabend
die Heimpremiere für Julian nagelsmann
als Bundestrainer gegen die Türkei im
Berliner Olympiastadion und das
verheißungsvolle alle 25 Profis sind im
Training voll einsetzbar der
Bundestrainer legt bei diesem Lehrgang
den Schwerpunkt auf das Verteidigen und
hat seit heute eine Option mehr der nach
Rückenproblemen konnte Malz Hummels
wieder am Teamtraining teilnehmen ob er
gegen die Türkei auf auflaufen wird ist
offen sollte er nicht spielen wird
Jonathan t in der Startelf erwartet der
torgefährliche Abwehrspezialist von
Spitzenreiter Leverkusen will seine gute
Form untermuern und die DFB Verteidigung
Stärken was auch nötig ist wir kriegen
zu viele zu viele Gegentore auf jeden
Fall und das ist aber immer immer was
mannschaftstaktisches was wir als
Mannschaft beheben müssen sie wollen
endlich mal wieder ohne Gegentor bleiben
in der Offensive dagegen läuft es ja
schon ganz
gut kein perfekter Start für die Frauen
des FC Bayern München in die Champions
League trotz einer 2:0 Führung zur Pause
schaffte die AS Rom bei den Deutschen
Meisterinnen kurz vor abfff durch
Manuela Giuliano doch noch den Ausgleich
zum 2:2 Endstand und noch Tennis
Rückschlag für Alexander SEV bei den ATP
Finals in Turin nach seinem auftagtssieg
unterlag er nun dem Russen daniil
medwedjev in zwei Sätzen und braucht für
die Halbfinalteilnahme Schützenhilfe
Alexander zwerre versucht positiv zu
bleiben obwohl er in den entscheidenden
Momenten einfach viel zu viele Fehler
macht wie etwa im tibreak des ersten
Satzes indem er den Weltranglisten
dritten medwedev bis 41 Führung klar
dominiert doch dann dieser verheerende
vololleyfehler statt 51 nur noch 42 und
trotzdem erkämpft er sich kurz darauf
bei eigenem Aufschlag Satzball doch den
vergibt er mit einem unfassbaren Fehler
so erreicht mit 7 Z6 und 6 Z4 vorzeitig
das Halbfinale zwerf dagegen muss morgen
unbedingt gegen Andrej robleev gewinnen
um noch eine Chance aufs Weiterkommen zu
haben und wichtig medwedev zuvor gegen
alkarass gewinnt dann klappt mit
Halbfinale schauen wir mal Danke Schön
chrütin der Deutsche Wetterdienst warnt
vor ergiebigem Dauerregen und Orkanböhen
im Schwarzwald genaueres gleich von
Katja horneffer das heute journal mit
Christian siers um
21:45 uh danke und bis
[Musik]
morgen guten Abend nach dem Tief Knut
kommt jetzt das tiefe Linus von
Frankreich heran das bringt Regen mit
Schnee und auch eine ganze Menge Wind
das geht heute Abend los und setzt sich
in der Nacht fort da s s sturmböhen
möglich in den Alpen vielleicht sogar
Orkanböhen also Böhen oberhalb von 117
km pro Stunde in den Mittagsstunden aber
lässt der Wind schon wieder nach aber
außerdem Wind gibt's auch eine ganze
Menge Regen 50 l Regen pro Quadratmeter
sind hier im Südwesten innerhalb von 24
Stunden möglich im Schwarzwald in
Staulagen sogar bis zu 90 l pro Quadrat
die Schneefallgrenze liegt so bei 600
700 m und auch hier im Thüringerwald
oder im Erzgebirge kann es für ein paar
Schneeflocken reichen sonst ist die
Nacht zum Teil auch trocken bildet sich
Nebel und es wird kalt
zwischchenchläßlich Holstein und dem
voglland sinken die Werte in Richtung
Gefrierpunkt oder knapp da drunter
milder bleibt die Nacht an den Küsten im
Westen und auch an der Donau und morgen
liegen die Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 3
und 9° und vor allen Dingen am Vormittag
kann es noch weiter regnen und schneien
hier in Süddeutschland freundlicher
sieht's aus von der Nordseeküste bis zum
Main am Samstag gibt's ein kleines
Zwischenhoch und mehr freundliches
Wetter danach aber wird's von Westen
wieder regnerisch und mild guten Abend